uh
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
the majority of world is ignorant to
what's really going on the oppression
you know it's one of the they say the
largest open-air prisons in the world
you know uh gaza what what are you i
mean
honestly i mean it's heartbreaking when
you see that when you see what's going
on down there and uh and you see them
well i've seen videos where you see
israeli snipers like laughing
uh as they're they're shooting guys just
running it's like a game to them where
they're just seeing kids running and
they just want to shoot them as a game
like for points or something like that
and we see something like that where
people are just protesting but it's
their land and they're they're getting
held into a little section where they
can't move they can't go anywhere like
my sister went down there uh she just
went down there last month for uh a
palestinian marathon and uh she said we
literally had to go through about 10
checkpoints just to get to 10 10
checkpoints just to get to my
grandmother's house and we should we're
going to stop there every every every
checkpoint getting checked for
everything asked what are we doing here
as why are we here and she's also
because they went as a piece of group
and uh some people had to get sent back
uh from the airport they get sent back
to the usa just because their social
media they posted anything that like
showed them uh protesting uh israel or
anything like that so like my sister
literally had to delete autoburg oliver
accounts before she went down there so
they're just trying to make it hard for
like uh americans or other uh
palestinians they want to go back to see
their home they want to they want to
make it where
american palestinian americans don't
want to go back home because it's so
hard oh man i got i had to stay at this
checkpoint for like an hour or two hours
or i'm stuck at the airport it's not one
it's 10. yeah well at the airport at the
airport yeah she was stuck at the
airport for three hours just to get out
of the airport and then said at every
checkpoint you're gonna stop that too
and you're staying there probably like
30 minutes something like that just get
checked so they're making aware if i'm
in america and i'm gonna be well what am
i gonna go down there for man they're
they're making it so hard for me to see
my own land for me to see my own family
that's not their grandmother or anything
down there and they're just making us
hate to go down there because that's
what they want they want they want all
the palestinians to leave and they
wanted to have a land for themselves
many people they also use this this
opportunity to create a division and to
try to promote that islam muslims hate
jews and whatnot but this is a zionist
agenda this is there's a difference
between zionism and then you know many
jews i've had like rabbi weiss some of
the chief even the chief
rabbi of palestine at that time he was
sending letters to the u.n because he
was showing how the muslims and jews
they were living together in peace their
children were go you know muslims are
watching their kids you know so now you
have even i've had like nico pilate he
wrote a book called the general son he's
an israeli jewish and he's speaking on
behalf of the
the
palestinian people
this is just open oppression any
american that goes down there and goes
and looks and sees from themselves this
is something that the world doesn't
really know because of many much of the
false propaganda you know what i mean
and that's why this was really good
report this is something that's going on
just recently 750 shot these are unarmed
civilians yeah
it's sad you know so these are you know
this is good like people like yourself
who are down there creating awareness
about this so you know the average
american good people they don't want to
they don't want to be sending their
three plus billion a year to go killing
innocent kids
yeah that's great like you said it's
crazy like the average american doesn't
know what's going on down there so like
when i saw i actually saw this article
it was uh
on this video and i posted it last week
on my like facebook and then i went back
to practice whatever and i had like
anthony and sergio pettis uh
two big time uh athletes and they're
asking no way is that really going down
down there and i'm like yeah no nobody
knows like people people don't
understand what those people are going
through on there man it's hard for them
to
kids can't go out there and play down
their kids they don't have a normal life
down there there's always explosions
always bombs going off it's kids are
waking up every day thinking am i going
to live today or am i going to die today
it's not i need to go to school or i'm
going to have friends with friends like
normal like normal kids should be having
fun today or i'm going to go to the park
today and play it's
man uh let's go protest day and maybe
we'll die maybe we won't die that's
that's how they're waking up every day
down there what's the food in the water
situation also yeah exactly like um i'm
also working on another uh a project
down here it's called the pious project
with fahima ref he just posted that he's
uh
he's uh sending like liters of water
down there and stuff like that so uh
hopefully we'll get a lot of people
donating to that as well because i heard
that when you go down there on one side
you have the illegal
settlements that you had like for
instance i want people to imagine you
got your home that your parents and your
great-grandparents passed down and
someone just comes and knocks on the
door and says you got to get out is this
what's happening these are the illegal
settlements that the u.n has condemned
united nations has condemned and now for
that side you have now water fresh water
you know electricity things we take for
granted and on the other side of the
palestinian side and this is not just uh
muslim these are also christians who are
being oppressed who are palestinians is
that right yeah yeah yeah like uh i just
saw an article another day where they
said
uh at the protest too there's christians
there's muslims and all the guys uh my
grandfather uh he just passed away uh
probably like eight nine years ago allah
and then uh
my sister went down there to for the for
the whole land lease and she said she
went down there to go see what's going
on with his land how it's going to pass
down to his kids
and then uh the government said well
here goes here goes the money for it we
took the land and it was like probably
like
three thousand dollars
for a huge piece of land that should be
going for big money or anything like
that and they just gave it to me said we
took the land this is what you guys get
we're not it's not like a negotiation
where you get to sell it or anything
like that they literally took his land
and he said this is the money for the
that get passed on to the kids instead
of my grandfather where he had a plan
where it's it's gonna be huge where he's
gonna build condos for his kids to live
on there and for them to
move their families down there to their
homeland but it got taken away from him
when he passed away yeah this is very
very sad and people compared to
south africa the apartheid state of
south africa
and the same thing here the open air
prison meaning that you have a wall you
know that well how big have you seen
that wall yeah i've seen it as you see
how huge is that wall yeah it's big it's
big yeah so it's like
they are trapped they can't even leave
right they're trapped inside uh the
water you know um the basic things that
we take for granted they don't have you
know the palestinians are some of the
most oppressed people but they're still
in there you know what i mean it shows
their commitment to god their commitment
to you know
family and they're not giving up how's
their spirit their spirits are strong
and this is what i think is driving many
of the the zionist forces again muslims
we don't hate their uh jews we don't i
mean jews muslims and christians you
know at the pinnacle the golden ages of
islam in spain you know i mean these are
golden years for jews you have a
professor doctor
i believe it's uh warrenstein he said he
writes
in uh it's called the jc journal in in a
how islam saved the jury you know i mean
how islam saved the jewish people when
they were you know being persecuted the
crusades and and the inquisitions they
were being persecuted they came into
muslim lands and the muslims welcomed
them same thing in palestine they were
welcomed but now you have even people
who have been
holocaust survivors who also condemn
what's going on to the palestinian
people muhammad ali he was also a strong
supporter nelson bendela
yeah
yeah it was huge like you said where
people nowadays assume that you hate
jews like i have people commenting i
think oh the ufc signed a jewish fighter
are you gonna fight him and i'm sitting
there like no he's not even my weight
class and they're like oh okay but you
probably hate him though right and i'm
like
no i don't hate like you said i don't
hate jews it's not the there's many
great jewish people out there that
condemn this whole situation jewish
people
opposed the occupation of palestine from
the very beginning
it was in the 1930s
before the creation of the state of
israel
when the politics began when the
zionists came into the region rabbi
zonnenfeld and at the time
wrote an article in one of the arabic
newspapers
it was called peace and truth
in which he wrote
he wants to he was the chief rabbi of
palestine
clarifying that the jewish people have
no demand over any place
holy and sacred by the muslims
yes
in
1947 a year before the creation of the
state of israel rabbi dushinsky
the chief rabbi of palestine at that
time
wrote a written testimony to the united
nations meeting in jerusalem
and i quote
we further more wish to express
our definite opposition our definite
opposition to any jewish do i do a
jewish state in any part of palestine
he was ignored by the united nations at
the time
several years several months later
a telegram to the united nations and
like success
at at least
leave jerusalem free
yes yes
and that request
was respected
this was how jerusalem was kept for
decades
jewish leaders the jewish communities
worldwide oppose the creation of the
state and still do
the philosophy of zionism is not only
causing a catastrophe for the
palestinian people
it is a true disaster for the jewish
people as well
it's the people that are supporting like
the zionism that's that's what it's all
about nobody know like the jewish
religion and everything like that it's
all close everybody's all these
religions are close together uh and they
all believe like similar things it's not
like i'm gonna hate you because you're
christian or i'm gonna hate you because
you're jewish
i i don't have a hate hate for a
religion i have a hatred for
for hate so like the zionist people they
hate palestinians they hate gaza they
hate uh palestine they hate palestinian
muslims that's that's that's a hatred
that's not a religion
yeah this is more of a nationalistic
movement a lot many of them don't even
believe in in in the almighty in god you
know
and and that's why you have many good
jewish people stepping up
and speaking against zionism and the
occupying force there and
may god almighty help to
bring peace to the suffering there and
shall we can create some
more awareness and some some good can
come from the little contribution that
we make to to talk about some of these
things where people are scared to kind
of talk about